you know me I've struggled yeah and I
have been as heavy as 830 pounds oh wow
but you wouldn't I would looked exactly
the same at 8:30 yeah and I do now and
that's what we're talking is a quad
midsection is a little bit thinner than
Brendan's always has been regardless of
what weight i okay right now I'm told
Torrance the question I could suck down
to 160 is a question and [ __ ] throw a
stick as bro says here's an advice to
stick in my hand what's the most you've
ever a truster everyone sitting what's
the most you've ever eaten was most of
everything yeah it was a Chinese
restaurant it was any kallu it yeah when
I was up there and I had had a couple of
polar bears with me yeah and we went
into the Chinese there's one Chinese
restaurant and ask you a real question
yeah how much is the most you've ever
eaten I had to keep up with the polar
bears and I was hungry you [ __ ] tell
me how much do your fortune really okay
so we how many Big Macs have you eaten
at do you think have you everyone if you
ever tried one of those con want me to
tell you you want me tell you a story
about Big Macs the truth okay so uh one
simple I don't drink anymore not that I
ever had a problem with it no no
actually you know you know me yeah I I
would either get good and pissed or like
not drink for months like I don't care
oh now I want to get drunk with my pals
so alcohol I'd never really you know was
good at drinking I don't think I was a
happy drunk I was just not my thing
I enjoy good scotch and good tequila I
haven't had it in around five years but
back in the day I was at a thing I was
at this comedy event in Canada and I was
with my good buddy Timmy O'Halloran whom
I've known for many years and we were at
this thing in London Ontario and we got
really drunk the night the big bash at
the end of this Canadian Comedy Awards
festival thing and then we had to drive
they gave Timmy Oh a Canadian Tire van
with nothing in the back just two seats
up front and no heat and he we drove
London to Toronto I think cuz we missed
our sedan or something it was pretty
great so here's me and Timmy oh and I'm
very hungover and we went to the
McDonald's because you want some
McDonald's yes it was like 4:00 p.m.
like I finally staggered out of that
room before and that we went up and he
goes and it's our McDonald's what would
you like to order I was like give me
just give me a number four with a
supersize it with a diet coke so like
some like quarter pounder meal or
something like thing and he goes okay
I said number four with coke diet coke
and I'll take give me a give me a number
three with sprite and then I go okay and
then give me a give me a Big Mac - okay
and a Big Mac and that two cheeseburgers
and two cheeseburgers fillet a fish one
just you want to flavor fish no I don't
want to play fish to fillet fishes to
fillet a fish would you have some
Nuggets if I don't want Nuggets would
you have some no if I order them
no you won't have even one because I
want Nuggets get Nuggets then you want
six Nuggets no do you want some I don't
want any if I get 20 Nuggets will you
eat Saget's will don't get 20 Nuggets
I'm paying I want 20 Nuggets if you have
some I will not have one I will not have
a Chicken McNugget I'll just get you ten
ten chick 20 chicken ten just 20 Chicken
McNugget find 20 chicken McNuggets and
it went on like that to where he was
like giggling like just order the
[ __ ] menu just get one yeah at an
apple pie and a blueberry pie and hot
fudge sundae no nuts that's it and it
was [ __ ] hilarious and so I ate all
that and then I I feel sick as [ __ ] yeah
then we pulled over down the freeway I
don't know what beautiful Canadian
freeway that was and I pissed and then
puked all over the side of it dude I
mean that I can't one-up that at all
yeah thank you tonight I've been on a
strict diet given me for this one-man
show tomorrow night the strict diet and
then there's a commercial for those KFC
golden chicken tenders have you seen it
there like you know Georgia golden
chicken tenders not like goddamn they
look good that was like two weeks ago a
couple days go by I see it again I'm
like [ __ ] I would love some of those
right now yeah yeah then late at night I
had my
pen I see that commercial I'm like well
haven't cheated in a while well [ __ ] it
and there's that app that the deliberate
dopost made to where there's a bra one
of those I get on a nurse and I'm like
well it was either six or 15 I'm like
well six kind of waste the time as we do
15 just save some for tomorrow yeah
you'll save saw order 15 oh the golden
[ __ ] fenders if they come they come
about I don't know hour later I'm so
tired like why I ordered these and I
open them up and I'm like god damn them
again and I started eating what and
remember I mean junk food in a while I
want it tastes like heaven makes tea I
know I ate all 15 nice eat all 15 I pass
out I wake up at 2:00 in the morning I'm
like oh my god and do my mouth is
salivating I love to throw up oh I go to
the bathroom and just [ __ ] that's by
the way my body was like you know no
they were so delicious
my mouth is watering right now they were
so good yeah he's Georgia golden
southern chicken tenders oh man that
sounds amazing by the way part of the
reason that you puked is because that
chicken is from those 15 pieces of
chicken are from as close as Northern
California in Sacramento perhaps as far
away as Beijing yeah yeah and and flesh
labs across you know it did it for me on
slabs we have flesh labs well you know a
lot of people is another thing I
shouldn't be sharing with you it's some
deep covers and dark ship stuff yeah
some stuff I've learned since we're
hanging out with Trump really your
knowledge bro
most of those most of the chicken that
you eat is is created in a lab I
questions I did not know that I thought
we're a long way off
no yeah yeah flush labs are things can
taste just like chickens expensively do
that positive perks man so it's really
expensive
yeah yeah I spend so much on those
chicken you know and this from a flush
lab I cut my accident in their [ __ ]
real cut my hand right off how does it
look can you see a scar all right it's
impressive flush labs
yeah all right hey you know you know it
does it for me where I won't order
chicken tenders anymore
my brother goes yeah those chicken used
to love him was Chicken McNuggets
the environment of snot deep-fried oh
that one I bet you I'm like well it did
it that'll ruin it for you that did it
people could say one thing and it'll
[ __ ] you up it'll just say they'll
describe something in a certain way and
you go I can't unless I'm hungry enough
yeah well why don't you tell them let's
deep-fry some snot and see what you
think about right now yeah yeah yeah
yeah watch your tongue
oh good what's gonna happen what are you
gonna do use some of that boxing you've
been doing
[Laughter]